à la parole de monsieur gilles lurton
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique monsieur le ministre
nos entreprises souffrent de distorsion
de concurrence entre les pays européens
tout d'abord en matière de coût du
travail de nombreux salariés recrutés
par des sociétés de prestation de
services de pays de l'est sont employés
dans d'autres pays comme l'allemagne ou
la hollande où le coût du pays d'origine
dans l'agroalimentaire plus de deux
tiers de ses salariés sont recrutés dans
ces conditions le coût de leurs
prestations et de moins de 7 euros de
l'heure en allemagne alors que le coût
de la main d'oeuvre dépasse 20 euros en
france distorsions de concurrence aussi
en matière de contrôle sur les
entreprises
nos entreprises agroalimentaires et plus
largement tout le secteur de
l'agriculture sont soumis à de très
fréquents contrôles sur la traçabilité
des produits
elles doivent respecter les règlements
européens concernant l'information des
consommateurs et sur les effets
préjudiciables à la santé propres à une
denrée alimentaire particulière c'est le
cas dans ma circonscription pour toute
la commercialisation en baie du mont
saint michel des huîtres de cancale et
des moules de bouchot nous ne pouvons
pas être opposé à lui tel règlement qui
constitue un gage de notre sécurité
alimentaire mais nous devons avoir
l'assurance qu'ils sont appliqués dans
les mêmes conditions dans les autres
pays européens
or tel n'est pas le cas un certain
nombre d'entreprises allemandes et
hollandaises par exemple ne respectent
pas toujours si règlement de traçabilité
les contrôles quand ils existent sont
loin d'être les mêmes que ceux imposés à
nos entreprises
aussi monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais connaître les moyens dont
vous disposez pour veiller au respect
des règlements européens par l'ensemble
des entreprises qu'elles soient en
france ou dans les autres pays de
l'union européenne
merci monsieur retour en la parole à
monsieur ministre de l'économie